i lose weight when i don't lift with
weights i wish i had that problem
i do i lose like it drops right off my
buddy jeff foley
he owns uh the uh the place where i take
my son
and tempus jim it's like a parkour gym i
think my son there
and he's like uh dude he's complaining
he's like i'm down to 161 dude he's like
shred and i'm like
[ __ ] that's where i'm like what'd you do
because i did this strict diet now i
can't get it back
like what diet was it yeah dude if if
thank you if i rode my bike as much as i
like you
i would waste i would waste away well
here's what's funny think if i
didn't ride my bike as much as i did i'd
be 300 pounds
because i eat like [ __ ] how much how
much how much
how quickly could you put on
15 pounds uh a week
if i didn't work out like i do and
sometimes like if i'm stressed
like when i was going through all the
[ __ ] you know with cal and all that when
i was really stressed about figuring
things out dude because i i like i like
stress eat
i mean that's why you and i get along it
gets that it gets out of control you do
you think you put on 15 pounds in a week
oh yeah
easily i'm trying to think cause i'm you
know i go i'm talking i probably have
there's weeks there i'd have seven eight
thousand calorie days
get the [ __ ] out but then i would ride
my bike for
two hours and then do another workout
but i just didn't feel good
but now i'm tightened up because last
night i couldn't sleep
and i was like man i want to do
something i need to go i need to get in
better shape i need a goal
and it's a round thick one like what i
do and i'm like oh i know what i'm gonna
do because my
my uncle used to run it i'm like i'm
gonna bike ride from san fran to la
for a charity it's like 530 something
miles
that's awesome yeah i'm gonna do it on
the specialized bike and i'm gonna have
a film crew with me film it
just you just me solo so
now i mean i so what's the route like
is it pch yeah the gold coast uh they
called the
gold coast uh trek like people do it all
the time
how long does that usually take somebody
i think it should take around four to
five days
it's like 530 something miles i think or
430 miles
so you're gonna do a hundred miles or so
a day yeah and how long is it
like i have no idea what what what is a
day like i'll do
30 25 to 30 miles on my mountain bike
but that's a little different so i think
i could do around
60 to 75 miles a day and divide that by
what how how far is that chin 60 miles a
day obviously is
240 if you're doing it in four days but
if it's 500 miles
that means you're talking about eight
days
plus and that's 4 800 that's 480 miles
with 20 left
see i don't want to do in eight days i
need to doing about four four days and
you stay away from my kids
how many miles 384
that's under 100 a day man that's about
four miles a day right i mean i'm sorry
if i did in four days
it's about 100 miles a day well if i
want to do in four days how many miles
you have to go
that's about 380 divide by four hold on
yeah pch is different yeah pch is
winding
yeah there's something he gets dicey a
lot yeah yeah look at some pictures
there's one bridge and there's the
incline
people are saying there's this incline
when you get yeah worth there it gets
pretty dicey do you know
do you know what pch for in four days is
going to be 164 miles
a day yeah dahl what's
let's see my goals do four to five
a week sounds good like solid yes a week
and what happened
what do you do you you how does that
work you pull over you eat
i mean what's the day look like you get
up at eight and you go i think you go
you get up at like
six a.m and you go all day
man yeah i'll tell you the one thing i
do want to do i want to do um
what was that hike in the movie i think
it was called um
everest no no no the wild the reese
witherspoon
the hike that goes from like um doesn't
it go from scent doesn't it go all the
way up
california what's that hypothetical
awful was any good
the book was i didn't watch the movie
the book
was amazing like the book
can i tell you one oh there it goes did
reese weatherspoon hike pct
the pacific crest
trail let me tell you that the book was
fun true story the book was amazing
amazing
but i but i've always wanted to do since
i read that i was like i gotta go
dude where and where does it go from san
diego to
[ __ ] where you had it when you go back
to
there it is see on the right the pacific
crest trail you go through california
oregon washington british columbia
canada nevada mountain range
150 yeah dude
but the book was fascinating you know
what i'm really obsessed with man
and these long treks when you're by
yourself
and like the the show alone i'm really
i've become fascinated with what you
learn about yourself in isolation
agree and i like riding my bike alone
and that's why
when i originally thought of the idea to
talk to my brother today and then
specialize and
they're like oh you can do with a group
of people like no i don't have to worry
about anybody else
i like to put my headphones on just go
because when you ride your bike do you
get lost in your brain
oh yeah and do you well sometimes i'll
i'll be like holy [ __ ] i'm here already
you lose time a little bit oh [ __ ] i'm
up here already
do you know what that is like for me
then i realized how far i could go back
like oh
[ __ ] it's almost i know this is gonna
sound but stupid and i'm probably
talking about something i don't know
about
but when that happens to me and i'm
doing something and it's it's almost
like you lose time you're like wait a
second
i just went 10 miles to me that's a form
of meditation
100 right 100 uh because you're you're
so good for your brain
yeah you're really turning your brain
you're just there
it's really where a lot of almost all
the ideas i have come from on that
bike right because i'm home dude it's
you know how it is with kids it's i hit
the door there's
you know i'm not thinking about anything
else but those kiddos and i'm with my
girl at night then maybe
you know when i lay my head down i'll
have some ideas if i can't sleep but
then when i'm on that bike man
yeah like that's where sick boy bike
club started that girl start
everything started do you know i read
and i again i could be wrong and i've
taken a lot of shots ahead and smoked a
lot of weeds so maybe i'm combining some
things here
but i did read that boys learn
and their imaginations and they think
better when they're moving
oh interesting so i actually like i'm
better
i think of more jokes more bits when i'm
i need to be up and walking and moving
it yeah if i'm stationary and i'm just
sitting at the computer
i don't have it i have if i come to the
computer with a thought yes
i can run with it but if i'm looking for
like yeah creative stuff
yeah i'm moving i had heard especially
young
uh kids in high high school and lower
that they learn better
it's why like in activities when they're
up and moving they do it
as well and it's just sitting and being
stationary that girls do better that's
why those
teachers like yeah we'll just zoom for
the year i'm like get the [ __ ] out but
for boys especially dude that they need
four or five-year-olds up and going get
on my face
man i have a question for you yes all
right so
i okay here's something about me i'm a
nice dude
one of the nicest until i'm not you have
a switch
well yeah i think just like everybody
everybody is some form of grey
listen i used to have a little anger
issue on stage
there was a clip online i don't know if
it's still up there from the tower
theater in philadelphia
of me going in
on this person someone kept talking or
they were yeah going in were they
heckling you
less me and more somebody else who had
just come on before me
yeah they were just talking through the
whole but i used to have a tiny little
anger issue
on stage just because of other things
that were happening in my life and
you know for me stage is really the most
honest me
sure you're gonna like so when there's
bad things happening on
in my life you talk about it yeah andy
you're gonna see it so i don't know if
it's still up there
but it was me just going some of my fans
used to call him that guy angry josh
oh damn yeah because see angry no no no
no
but angry josh look i grew up with three
older brothers
again i'm cool until i'm not let me ask
it probably takes a lot for you to get
to angry josh
does you know the big thing is is
somebody who i feel like has a complete
disregard
for other people or somebody who feels
like they live by a different set of
rules so let me ask your opinion on this
and i may have gone too far i also i'm
not the kind of guy that you want to
start a prank war with yes
because you know you start at hey let's
scare him and i end with
that [ __ ] on his face when he's sleeping
well let's have him suck my idea yeah
i don't know that that's a prank i just
tied your shoes together now i'm sucking
it
um so uh all right so
this dude i'm walking my dog now i am
recently this is
a two days oh [ __ ] i am
this is where i land on masks everybody
i'm not a doctor
so and i'm respectful of other people so
my thing is like look i'm not a doctor
and i generally play things safer than
not safe
so until everybody knows everything
about it
i err on the side of safety sure no
matter what right but if i'm i'm out
walking my dog it's 6 45 in the morning
outdoor in my residential neighborhood
with nobody on the street
i'll have my mask in my hand just in
case i pass by somebody or somebody's
wearing a mask and i'm respectful and i
put mine on
okay but if i'm by myself and there's no
and we're outdoors
i'm i'm not even if you're around people
outdoors you probably shouldn't have a
mask on but i'll wear just so people
shut the [ __ ] up i do hey fam do you
guys get bored with your workouts are
you locked down and quarantined or maybe
you just can't get to the gym because
you're busy with your kids or your girl
or your
dude whatever it is you're bored at home
you don't want to be on the treadmill or
the elliptical you i need something new
man i need something that's going to
keep me engaged learning things
keep me motivated well i got you covered
i'm talking about fight camp
if you've ever done boxing kickboxing
maybe you haven't you just thought about
it
now is the time you gotta check out
fight camp man
you can start boxing from home that
means amazing at
home boxing equipment along with new
boxing body weight workouts
released every week it's the perfect
at-home workout for anyone
men women children families great for
all fitness levels you guys will
freaking dig it man you will dig it are
you new to boxing cool man
they have their 12-week starter program
teach you the fundamentals of boxing
when you get a great workout every time
i'm talking about high
intensity interval training workouts are
structured like traditional boxing
rounds
three minutes of intense boxing and body
weight exercises
then one minute of rest access over 400
different workouts
for all fitness levels and skills you're
gonna get hooked
fight can't keep you super engaged
focused and
uh in the zone man there's a ton of
varieties they have a ton of workouts
you can try
fight camp for free just download the
fight camp app and select the workout of
your choice this is a great way to test
your trainer see where you're at
you can buy now pay letter pay later
there's uh
financing right there's monthly payments
if you can't afford it we got you
covered man
you can save on the commute going to the
gym forget that do it in your garage
doing your parking lot whatever the hell
you want to do
don't have to go to the gym anymore with
fight camp
and the whole family gets this gym
workout for under 20 per person
fight camp offers flexible financing
like i told you guys zero percent apr
and right now you guys can try fight
camp for 30 days with the money back
guaranteed son
just go to join fightcamp.com fighter
that's right
try fight camp for 30 days if you don't
love it they'll refund your money
train like a fighter and turn your sweat
into results to try fight camp for 30
days
just go to joinfightcamp.com fighter
join fightcam.com fighter
so yeah let me guess you're walking your
dogs okay i said put on a mask
so check this out i'm walking from
across the street other side of the
street
guy without a mask on
gets into his car window down and
here's what i'm not okay with man i
don't like passive aggressive [ __ ]
i really hate i don't i don't like you
being an [ __ ] to my face but at least
i know who you are yeah
and so window down so he knows i can
hear him
goes [ __ ] [ __ ] put on a mask
and i go hey man i'm
i'm standing right here yeah i go you're
not have a mask
he goes i'm in my car out [ __ ] i go
yeah but you're screaming out the window
like you're putting as much out there as
i am because i'm not walking up and down
put on a [ __ ] mask and i was like hey
dude
you say your awards in the mail i said
hey there's no
reason to be screaming at me man we're
neighbors i get we're tense
and i was just trying to diffuse it see
how the shape yes
there you go and his dog that's how
anybody out of shape or older it's like
put on a [ __ ] map my dog barked at
him right
and he goes and you shut that [ __ ]
dog up too wow
and i go hey dude i go this is and i
said something back to him
and he goes [ __ ] you i better not see
you around here again right
so i want to ask you remember i told you
i'm not the type of dude
to start these games with tell me if i
went too far you [ __ ] on his lawn
i last night
my dog took [ __ ] i picked it up in the
bag he's gonna hear this you know this
right yeah he picked it up in the bag i
hope he does
and in [ __ ] i wrote be kind on his rear
view
on his back window tight move how do you
now where do you
where do you fall on that too far ah no
i'd rather you do that than get a
physical comfort that's not my thing man
because that's not my thing
i'm not going to physically i don't i
don't want those buttons also
you don't get to be an [ __ ] with a
computer did you have a i did it i did
it with the plastic bag that i picked
the [ __ ] up with i would throw up just
put
my finger and [ __ ] so i i couldn't do
either
listen man but for me like i'm not do
you want to know
okay this is where i'm at when you when
people play jokes with me
that i just don't know where the line is
when i was in college
i had a friend of mine this dude i
worked out with who who scared me coming
out of my bathroom once ah
and i was like ah and he goes oh [ __ ]
got you man pranks here you're never
gonna get me
prankster and i go okay so and he dude
would do
he went as far as when i would go to his
dorm room he would
before i walked in he would grab his
toothbrush and his hairbrush and put him
in places where he could see right i go
i got to use your bathroom man here's
your bathroom
he's like sure i go i got to take a dump
you all right with that yeah
so i didn't have to get done i had
grabbed his workout hat
and um i jerked off in it
and so the next day when i saw him
working out he had sweat
he had sweat just rolling down his
face so me and my friend knew who'd
known what i did we were just laughing
the whole
we made sure we did extra cardio my man
my man was just so we let him do it for
two days
and we fight
but like yeah i just i'm not gonna play
those games i'm not that guy
i'm not that guy man i don't play any of
those games oh i do but you but you and
our older brother beat the [ __ ] out of
each other
yeah so we played jokes on each other
yeah that makes sense yeah but like as
far as confrontation goes i mean it
would have i mean you'd have to hit my
kid or my girl
but i would never never never you're
talking about lawyers especially
these [ __ ] in california no one's
actually get like
when we're in like the thicker cove and
i was riding without a mascot on my bike
going 30 miles an hour
and these two dummies on horses like
we're a mess you [ __ ] idiot we're in
the middle of nowhere yeah and i get off
my bike and start arguing again i'm like
well your horse doesn't have a mask
and it's just you know they're like well
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm like
okay
i was there tomorrow and i was like i
mean there's no cameras around
so who's starting to fight with you dude
that is [ __ ] from like the palisades
that's
his girl was hot so i gave him a pass
what are we gonna do dude yeah like you
realize i'm gonna twist your
[ __ ] neck up there's no k there's no
there's nobody here no one around just
out of curiosity say
something i would call you how big is
that dude how big is he
all right let's say 200 pounds shredded
you like he's in shape okay it doesn't
matter
i'll call you say josh would i'll film
it for you what do you want me to do
this guy oh piledriver
sure what should i do to the horse
like what do you want me to do with this
horse man i think you hey josh you want
a horse dude i think you pile drive him
and then you put his girl on your horse
and you ride off
that'd be sick later dude she's like no
it'll
move miles down the road i mean it's so
weird though man
it's so hostile i can't imagine that
i'm with you man like in order to get me
in a physical confrontation at this
point
i'll get heated but y'all argue with you
i
i mean i like a good argument yeah me
too you know
there was a guy the closest i came to
physical was actually
two weeks ago when somebody called beth
a [ __ ] dang for not wearing a mask
no we're walking you know we have those
slow streets in our neighborhood
you know like the city of la has put up
like giant cones and stuff and they turn
some streets in the neighborhood into
slow streets
because gyms are closed so you can walk
your kids and ride your bikes uh
interesting and you're not supposed to
ride your drive your cars up and down
the slow streets oh you can't drive your
cars if you you have to live
on that street oh i'm totally never
heard of that dude it's super cool
there's a couple in my neighborhood
there it is so you can it's for people
who want to ride their bike or walk with
their kids
and get outside right low slow streets
garcia not just slow streets
right so it's it's fine it's kind of
cool and this dude came
zipping down the street and be cool when
he turned
he uh and you're allowed to walk in the
middle street that's a deal he almost
hit somebody and beth was like slow down
[ __ ]
and he screeched and he backed up and he
said what'd you say [ __ ]
and i was like damn it yeah because if
you insult my girl now you can't have it
that's you know what i mean i was like
damn it again still not gonna physically
hurt him
but pee on him yeah i piss on him but
damn it
like by the way also the reverse how
many times
in the world do you think a woman
has said something to a bouncer or to
another dude
and a guy's been like no [ __ ] no oh dude
now i gotta
i know i gotta get in there now
nightmare dude yeah
but he uh he backed it up and he got out
of the car man he got out of the car got
out of that car
and what'd you do well i had my dog in
my dog is a deterrent your dog's pretty
gangster man i've seen that he was a
deterrent because my dog's super chill
when the guy
came out and started pointing his finger
and my dog was like hey is this is it go
time
the dog's like is this happening is this
is this is this how we're doing is this
still
simulation or am i down to [ __ ] this
dude up yo
he got real real quick and i didn't know
if he was gonna but the guy
you know what else man and what i found
out about myself because this dude got
out of the car
super tight tank top short shorts and
this is interesting so i'm not
a hateful dude i'm not racist i'm not
homophobic i'm not misogynistic i feel
like i'm pretty good with everybody i'm
even killed i want people to live
love have a good time but you know when
he came out and called beth a [ __ ]
do you know my first instinct the f word
yeah and and not because you know it's
gonna hurt
that's it i know that's it you know what
i found i walked away and i told beth i
go you i almost did you drop the fbi no
i said i almost called that guy
something he didn't want me to call him
well you want to hurt him hurt your wife
it has nothing to do
with how i feel no it's all about what
can i say
in this moment that's going to hurt you
the moment do you dwell on like when you
ride away are you going through the
fight in your mind
you know what i did for a second and i
was like i feel like i
actually i didn't escalate it best thing
didn't escalated because i don't think
about it
like when i have a confrontation
whatever it is fight with my girl
fight with those stupid horse people
someone yells at me bikers
all the time yeah you all the time i
don't even
i don't give it any energy as soon it's
just the way my brain works like right
and it's like throwing interception
all right next really i don't even i
don't know
the next day someone's like hey that
dude yelled yesterday i'm like i don't
think so
what does stick with you anything if if
i think i'm
being like sighted on a business deal if
i think someone's trying to take
advantage of me in business yeah like
maybe this thing or
hey can you do this i'm gonna do this
and then i start looking up from the
outside like oh
i see what you're doing that can drive
me nuts and will that stick with you
like i'll keep me up at night and will
that stick with you like as far as that
person goes from here on out you're like
that's who that guy is 100
100 you know what's funny is when it
comes to business
a lot of times and if i catch it i'm
just like yeah that
that's business like if that stuff
doesn't stick with me
that stuff for me is like look he's
gonna try i go into every business deal
like everybody's got their
own agenda everyone has their own cards
they're playing their cards
even your agent has their own agenda 100
right so the people who are still
working for you supposedly
it's a weird dynamic though because you
know we had these big
uh kids on that the who they're like
huge youtubers and i do these videos and
they're huge and
it's just the business has changed a
little bit
and i'm even part of that because if you
go to ca
and you go all right well what's brendan
do is he an actor like no he gets
offered roles
okay but he's a comic yeah he's a torn
comic
uh okay and what else podcaster this he
has these businesses
so it's like they really don't because
they're such an old-school model
they really don't know how to and they
know that what i'm saying i'm not
talking about they really don't know how
to
help me if that makes sense like i do
all the deals yeah everything goes
through me
and because they'll be like you know
this guy do this for you for this price
i'm like
well dude you know my show's ten times
as big as that i do it twice a week and
yeah
this is my rate for doing an ad and like
what they're like yeah dude
like oh [ __ ] sorry man like yep all good
it's just such kind of a different model
but you are
i mean so to me the agencies
are one generation always one generation
behind
but you're the new form of what
entertainment is
we you know one another thing that rogan
showed all of us is that
you can do it you can run your business
and not everyone's gonna be as big as
his obviously
but you can run your business now by
yourself
basically obviously you want some people
to book you and
somehow but you can run home base
by yourself and that's and it used to be
dude that
so say i uh the first tv deal i got
was massive but that's how it money used
to be
used to be so big but you used to get
the whole pie at once
right and now you get pieces of the pie
so in order to make a whole pie you have
to do what you do which is a lot of
different [ __ ] yes
and it used to be they would be like
here's your pie but me and theo were
talking about this like
you know theo's pitching this cartoon
he's talking about this and it's like
you know theo's just like me has his
merch has his shows and his big shows
and
for whatever reason because we're in
this world you want to be validated by
that world yeah but that world wants the
exact thing we have a
loyal fan base who tunes in and listens
every week
that's what they want so it's like why
do you need to
just do it on your own dude just to show
in your idea
you could just fund it yourself book
your friends
have a crew shoot it and put it on your
page and it's gonna get more views than
whatever network you're going to go with
that is exactly
but then but there's still something in
us we're like it'd be nice if
whatever netflix or comedy central or
you know paramount signed off on it's
like
but [ __ ] them like why
one one it's weird right yes it won it's
less worse it's kind of like how rappers
want to be athletes and athletes want to
be rappers
it's kind of like how mainstream actors
want to be comedians or podcasters
communes and podcasters kind of be
mainstream you know what i'm saying
they want to cross that without a doubt
man
which it's weird because it's like but
some shows i get off from like how many
people watch them like
i'll just take a piss on youtube dude oh
a hundred and that's not even bro i'm
not even that big of a name but it's
like
how many well i'll just do this it's so
crazy when i looked at
honestly this one this is when it sunk
in for me i looked at some of the
numbers on my
youtube channel and i was like what is
that getting
and then i thought about the shows that
i do by myself
and i was like wait a second where is
this better served
handing it off to somebody else or just
doing this myself well think about what
if you hand off somebody else and you
know
more so than me but i've been there
where you have your show on a major
network
and there's seven captains on the ship
and has to go through this this this guy
thinks this is funny this guy thinks
this
and you're like by the time he gets done
with like gee this isn't funny anymore
do you remember fun anymore
you remember that show that i had i
asked you to be on the joshua show yes
okay so i one of the things that i did
is i made sure i was booking my friends
who never got opportunity to do network
tv
and that were friends of mine i had
tripoli on
you they're not at nobody's asking
triple no because they don't know what's
coming out of his [ __ ] mouth yeah
he's a loose guy he's a wild guy right i
had tripoli on i had sickler on i had
jay larson on but i also had joe diaz on
right
and um i was like hey guys i'm i'm
picking who
is on these shows and they were like
cool so they let me pick
but i didn't have anything to do with
the edit you asked sickler because he
was on that
show oh dude joe diaz got out this is
all you heard him say and uh my one of
my oldest friends joey diaz what's going
on man
and then maybe maybe they let them keep
one other line that's what time's toxic
that's the way it works but that's the
thing is that because it was in somebody
else's hands
they got to dictate ultimately what was
being put out there
and and it wasn't the best product
because here's the deal you know what
you do well
and you know what your fans want and
that's not always in tandem with what
that network wants
no you know what i mean but also the
other thing is too is when you do
something like that that can get
canceled at any single given moment
when they're not seeing whatever they
needed so that's gone
yeah well and and which is a scary way
to live dude well one of honestly dude
pre-coveted why i loved stand-up
is because my i was like you can never
fire me from stand up
you can no matter what happens in the
world i can always find a mic
and that to me was the ultimate job
security which is
look maybe i don't play the rooms that
always play the rooms i want to play
maybe
the following falls off but i'll always
be able to work somewhere
yeah and and that's what for me is this
was the scariest part of
when that went away when that went away
because
that was for for me the thing that was
like i can always do this
like we had paul wall on fight on uh
king of the sting
and we we're talking about music in
covid and he's like
actually like it because it's forced
musicians and artists get so much more
creative
because you can't go to the big
production store he can't go to the big
you know uh booths anymore and put out
this
label put this out he goes so people are
getting super creative because they're
forced to
he's like so i actually i actually think
covid was good for for the music
industry because it
forced people to adapt which i in with
comics
it's for some and some can just write it
out right but some are doing you know
these zoom things which i'm not a fan of
or they're doing the drive-ins
or you know whatever they're it's
fortune get creative have you been
writing
i've been writing yes what i've been
writing but for me it
forced me to uh
i guess it as far as like work wise not
not
family wise family it's been koba's been
[ __ ] great me too the best me too the
best
but as far as like business-wise like
yeah forced me to
really hone in on king the sting and
fighting the kid and below the belt and
figure out what i want to do
and then you know i launched thick boy
merch during the pandemic stuff like
that
so i've had more time to focus on that
are you when you're doing the road man
you know you go on thursday through
sunday and it is just there's
you know you're exhausted yeah i just
had to get the best job in the world but
it's exhausting before i go
uh are you are you going straight from
here to a merchant ship
are you are you auditioning for hipster
popeye what's going on are you talking
about this yeah i know
[Music]
no it's like so we have that cartoon on
king of steam yeah and
we have this merch lane theo walks in he
goes hey
they sent me these out you know they
they're [ __ ] stupid and taz i'm like
that's dope he's like you like him like
i would rock the [ __ ] out of that he's
like
really i'm going yeah it's from the
cartoon dude when we have the cartoon
yeah polly tune
and so i put on he's like oh it's
actually pretty dope so they're just
like one offs has
the the kingston label on that you were
like what goes well with capris yeah i'm
like what could we wear this with
now what technically just fashion wise
because you know i'm not this is
i mean it's not bad though what are they
what's happening what are these these
are jeans we can roll
like you make them jeans here but when i
wear these i like to roll them up in
almost a capri thing
yeah this one it's hot out here it's
very european it's very euro
yeah it's very boat boatish here's the
thing i feel like if you weren't
a large man more people would say
something to you about you think
i think so i think i'd look cooler if i
wasn't so large really
yeah my style would look way better
fashion's harder for a big person yeah
how come it's dude you try finding a
size anything cool that's also a lot of
stripe on a big part this is a yeah and
it's in
so you think fashion is better on a
small person way better
look at nba players they look like
[ __ ] and it's all custom-made too by
the way like
going to gooch going to a high fashion
place
like off-white because urban's gonna
have bigger like sizes but like
you go to gucci armani like dude i can't
step foot arm on it can i tell you one
look
i am not in favor of it all you know the
short short but kind of the dressy the
shorts but we're like the dressy top
for girls no for the guys like when you
see lebron james and russell
yeah yeah i know that's not see i dig it
i can't do
i dig it the shorts with like the yeah
the shorts and the matching shorts it
looks like a
like a onesie yeah yeah
what like the other day uh j.r smith i
forget what instagram posted maybe
kicks or something yeah this one here
yeah this is not my
but he but he you can't he admits he
looks cool he looks all right
he would look like [ __ ] for me i
don't know
i think it'd be better if you didn't
have the socks like that but dude
summer suit attire what is your most
regrettable fashion phase
for you and is there any fashion you're
doing now that you know i know i'm going
to hate this in 10 years probably this
scarf
i pry the scarf my kid in 10 years and
be like
why are you always wearing that gay
scarf all the time
like was the pandemic he was like when
was the pen dude 220
no this video is from 24 dude okay i
know i just rock with it now i get a new
tie-dye one coming it's gonna be so sick
is it yeah i'm gonna wear it in here
just for you dude i really appreciate
that thanks
yeah that would be really nice here my
i've had some bad
fashions jinko jeans i like i wish there
was picture man you told me you went
jenko gene oh dude they were
i mean each leg was this were you a big
dude in middle school no
i i wasn't baked i get to really college
i was kind of i was like
in in like uh high school i was like six
two one seventy
these jeans man i was the kid on the um
i was basically on the far left but
they're green and i wear a michigan
jersey
i look like such an [ __ ] michigan
like
football jersey or basketball chris
webber
that's a terrible look horrible i
there are two looks that i looking back
i'm not super psyched on
one was been through some [ __ ] though
yeah because you're older so it's like
i i need like a there's dope stuff from
every kind of air like the 70s look
that's some dope [ __ ]
i was i was i'm a child in this i know
i'm sorry i thought it was brian yeah
i know you're you're you know your red
glasses you wear yeah you know who wore
those
who do you know who wore those uh
nirvana kurt cobain oh yeah yeah yeah
the white the white ones because i was
reading this article and i go down this
rabbit hole
uh nirvana i meant to snap a picture
it's almost your exact glasses dude
they are some of my favorites you know i
live down the street there he is
i lived down the street from him when he
shot himself
oh really did you hear it no but i
couldn't get to my [ __ ] house
did you did you see his uh wife
courtney running away i had blood on her
items did not
see that definitely commit suicide i did
not see that
have you seen the documentary on hbo i
have you watch that you're like
let's arrest this [ __ ] yeah dude that
but then with documentaries there's
always
there's always a bias you know 100
percent there's like you're making a
murderer i've had so many because
i was going hard in the paint for brent
brendan dassetti and for that other guy
hard in the paint for stephen right and
then people who are in the town like
dude stop we here we watch in wisconsin
that guy is a murderer and they because
they know they follow the whole thing
like
and they they'll give you like all the
[ __ ] he's done like oh but that's like
what was that
one i think it was on netflix maybe hbo
about the woman this a writer he was he
wrote novels
his wife was found dead staircase he had
yeah staircase where the one where he
she got it to the owl staircase the owl
theory yeah
like it could be the birds like or he's
killing [ __ ]
do you think he killed her oh yeah oh
yeah did you see uh
i think it's jenks did you see that he
killed like yeah i'm pretty sure it's on
hbo
jinx or something like that type of
looks jeans 100 you think staircase you
think oh yeah he's killing [ __ ]
you really think so i i didn't i thought
oh the the but have you seen jinx
durst oh no yeah i have seen this yeah
spoiler in three
two one's been out for three years suck
my [ __ ] so
he's miked up he's not hyped up it's the
most amazing 15 seconds of tv
jaw dropping have you guys seen him i
know the part i'm spoiler free right now
all right he's my
so they go through the whole thing
you're like god did he do it he two
girls two wives are murdered
you're like i don't know he's miked up
he's a crazy senile old man
and he's miked up taking piss he goes
ugh did i kill him of course i [ __ ]
killed him you're like
it is the innocent people don't talk
about the craziest
best part in documentary history in
history and but but for me
you know what it proved a sociopath
is believable yeah oh yeah because i
think they
believe it in a way they believe their
own lies eventually yeah because you
would watch him and he never blinked he
never looked away he
i mean he had some weird ticks he was
crazy dude but
nana's b what do you think about it dude
did you see don't [ __ ] with cats
yes oh how about the people with no
jobs just on facebook i
i had no idea what that was going to be
about and i thought let me just see
and i watched the whole thing in the
night with my mouth
[ __ ] girl i stopped watching halfway
because you know when they show the
the snake eating cat yeah like i was
like i can't watch this
so i stopped watching god damn it so
then finally you never finished it oh
[ __ ] yeah i found a [ __ ] a week later
i'm like can we please just get through
this i'll tell you if cats die or
whatever
and then we got through it it's riveting
but so good it goes also though you know
what
it was fat one of the most fascinating
parts for me was the mom's teeth
they were interesting mom's teeth i was
like yeah yeah what is happening
please don't bite anybody i what was
fascinating though was the mom you know
why because she's still down for her son
she's like okay not a cat person right
so like i'm i was thinking
all right do you believe eve
at what point do you not believe your
kid
do you know what i mean like do you know
what i'm saying it'd be so hard if your
kid said look you dead in the face and
be like you know me papa
you know i would never do that it'd be
tough you'd be like yeah well then
yeah dude right how about he cut that
dude into pieces then wear his shirt out
toss the body in the back but how calm
was he oh my god
how you know when everybody got caught
because he's such a narcissist he goes
to
wi-fi cafe and he's researching himself
you know what's crazy is that like how
calm these guys are same with durst
if i if i had a surprise for you like a
surprise present
i'd walk in and you'd think i'm on meth
you're like
i can't yeah i cannot you dude secrets
i'm not good with
this this this these [ __ ] who
go
complete dead eye and still sleep at
night everybody cut up that body
slept fine that night would you i how
i'm better with other people's blood
than i am with my blood
oh i'm not good with any blood well me
too i guess i don't like any of it
yo you one of the funniest things joe
diaz
not good with blood straight up fainter
no really big dude when you see
people like that who yeah they see blood
they faint big dude and
you he gets crazy and all yeah yeah big
but i
i i think for me like
one of the i'm starting to think the
more
the more believable you are you're
guilty
like the mo when you are like carol
baskin guilty
you can't be that dead fast believable
that's what a sociopath
she's crazy uh [ __ ] joe exotic is
great like they're all
dumbass groups they're all i gotta tell
you just the whole group is [ __ ]
that whole show the truth of the matter
is
from a story tellers point of view the
story was
you could have done it in an episode and
a half but the people
the people were so crazy that you were
like yeah i'll keep watching i kind of
see where this is going
but how about they're like there's gonna
be a part two i'm like kind of all set
yeah where are we gonna go for a hundred
percent kind of set
all set i did start to get in and start
to look around more
with um uh what's it called the autistic
the uh
oh autistic love love on a spectrum love
on a spectrum have you seen it yet cat
hey you know you know the guy that i
like the most i know you like the
the homeboy the main guy the [ __ ] who's
funny who who was like i'm looking for a
wife i'll be a grade a
yes and my favorite part is he they go
it's his first date and they go what do
you think he goes
i'm thinking what my wife is going to
say at the funeral and they're like yeah
yeah
dude but you noticed what was great is
that his mom and dad you could tell
they laughed at what he said i'll go the
red head for me with the glasses oh
sorry nightmare good though
she was she's a nightmare haven't been
on date anything
she's farting on the day farting wow
farts and goes oh my god i can't believe
this happened the guy's like
you know what let's pretend it even
happened the guy was great i guess you
know what let's pretend
farts just wide open on the date burps
and then just like when she gets excited
she jumps around
and but she was just my problem with her
nice person
difficult man like she was super
difficult yeah i mean like everyone else
was super friendly i'm like goddamn
[ __ ]
yeah she was not friendly tough to fart
on a first date i think oh that poor
girl on the far left though
she dude then how about the two who were
autistic got together
now i call [ __ ] another kid being
autistic her husband
who has always wanted sex all the time
you know what i think he had like into
comic books yeah he had a different
form of autism he seemed definitely more
more highly functional but i loved those
he seemed normal they they were so happy
with each other this dude looks like he
used to play an arios speedwagon
do you know what i mean like this dude
this dude to me seemed normal yeah i
loved it but it's like it's like the guy
who's like you know what i think i might
have a better look
in the autism pool they
they love the [ __ ] swim around in
here oh they love each other you like
grammar teeth
dudes sexy as [ __ ] like grammar titties
and stuff
where are you with by the way do you and
your girl you you public display of
attention people
i'm not no i'm not i mean like i'll i'll
grab some hands hands
and like yesterday your mom's around
like her mom turned out like to do
something like grab her titties
to meet them in front of her mom no her
mom would turn her oh okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i've never been a
makeout
like no oh god the makeout people you
know when someone's in line in front of
you and
you can hear like that oh and you're
like
14 yes first of all
not for me dude no you don't have i
don't want to have a boner around a
bunch of other people
no i know i'm for sure going to get one
if we start kissing because then my
brain goes it's go time
yeah what but my wife will always say my
genes can't control
you you can't fit well you can't fit in
here yeah you see everything
but my wife when she says she's like i
started making out with her
like at the house and then i start to
get into it but you know booty and boobs
and she's like no no can we just make
out i'm like
no that's not oh no why why and she's
like this is just fun just to kind of
and then think about what might happen
later
oh no no no no no this is it's time it's
go time my guy goes it's go
time yeah we don't do it we're going to
prom well she says she's like
why can't we just kind of tease each
other and then come back to it later i'm
like oh no
that sounds terrible talk about blue
balls yeah that's that doesn't matter
strip club yeah i'm sorry i'm at
cheetahs
that's why i don't go to school because
i'll get singles out what
the reason i hated strip clubs and i
never quite got it was never went to the
boom boom room
but i don't want to have to pay you
because i can touch my dick for free
yeah
do you know what i mean like when i used
to go with a bunch of people and it was
drinks and every it was like a fun group
even but that would make at least sense
to me somebody's bachelor party
but going to the boom boom room i gotta
buy you what a 400
bottle of what the hustle you they do
that do they the bet they are
the ultimate hustlers because once
you're like look i don't want and then
that knee hits your dick like
one bottle yeah yeah just take my credit
card yeah
what happened to our friend dude he just
gave it to his dad's platinum credit
card
and then we were like he's still in
there so we left and he didn't realize
it's per dance
he was in there tonight oh dude
thousands of dollars
i don't hate the hustle no by the way
did you just
dummies get the hustle so it's like know
what you're signing up for absolutely
if you if you're easy to hustle
someone's gonna find you but did you see
that bella thorne was getting some
backlash from her people
yeah dude because she did the two
million and then i guess the backlashes
they changed like the we have it as a
current event
apparently what happened was she there's
an option on only fans to do a
pay-per-view
and so for whatever the cost is you can
buy a pay-per-view and see whatever that
thing is so it's like
on top of your subscription you can buy
this extra thing
and she was saying that she was gonna
post nude photos of herself
on the pay-per-view charging 200 for it
people asked her so when you say nude
photos you mean nude nude because
i guess your only fans feed was more of
like her instagram photos
like her yeah provocative photos not
nude photos
and people want to see her nude so they
paid the extra two hundred dollars on
top of their subscription
jesus and then she ended up uh the
pay-per-view
yes so 200 one time you see this one
time yeah
and uh i don't know
details carry on um but what ended up
happening is she didn't post a naked
photo on there
she scammed a bunch of people a bunch of
people then asked only fans for a refund
they couldn't afford to do the whole
payout and so a bunch of policies then
changed because bella thorne
didn't post new photos so can you do
that to somebody
like wouldn't that be fraud yeah i can't
i mean can you
do can you promise something i guess and
not that i don't even know
well i'm sure only fans is like wait
what someone promised nudes and didn't
do it
that's the only fans like who would do
this why because all you're doing is
killing your own career
she's she single-handedly [ __ ] sex
workers how did she do that
because now uh before you could tip
however much you wanted and now the tip
is capped at a hundred dollars
and the price for a pay-per-view is now
fifty dollars and
then also because because they paid 200
and and then also 50
well people were like oh i'm not seeing
her titties and brush i want my money
back
so only fans go it's going to take 30
dollars to get money back instead of
seven now i guess it's
actually uh what's happening right uh no
[ __ ] about only fans so what i read was
uh
people aren't only fans the creators now
usually they had a week to cash out from
the last weeks uh like so they get paid
basically every friday
yeah every friday they'll get paid but
now it's gonna be once a month
so she [ __ ] some people yeah and she
came out and she
uh tried to say that she was only really
on only fans
not necessarily to make money but to
end the stigma of sex workers she's
doing research for a movie but did you
hear the director of the movie
the director of the movie was like i'm
not making a movie with her about only
fans i have no idea what she's talking
about
she's kind of [ __ ] right the monthly
thing unless she posts a naked picture
and
fully redeems herself that's how that's
all you got to do
yeah but even then the new policies are
in place for all these sex workers so
you can't get the same type of payments
she can just refund the money to people
i mean that
is a possibility i mean that's what
they're gonna do but it's gonna take a
hot second
mm-hmm but what i don't know what was
shannon why the two why
promise the two she's gonna get away
with scam without
sending a [ __ ] nude pic it's a
straight-up skill
they paid for it i by the way i'm just
putting it out there only fans
i would 100 go straight nuts out for a
million dollars for the month
zero doubt about it uh-huh if you're
saying in a month oh jack off on only
things
me too 100 if you're saving a million
dollars i will jack off every once a
month yep without uh
hard i'm gonna do it anyways hot
lighting i'll make sure it's good
lighting yeah
we'll film it you know what let's get a
four camera shoes cat's feet
i think if you're going to put up four
cameras i think one just for the face
multi-cam yeah one's gonna edit it
together i think you do a camera from
under so people can get the free money
to watch 250 to finish money shot yeah i
like that
man although there's there's limits now
right uh
i mean not necessarily on the content
you put out but
the limits on monetarily what would be
the lowest amount you would have to make
for the month
for that to happen a mill i'm ill oh
god dude i got kids and they're young
yeah i got old kids who've seen me
good i've walked around the house naked
because i forgot they were in the house
the other thing is i'd lose every gig i
have
if yeah showtime's like you're jacking
off for a million dollars yeah
i think so guys yeah like we're gonna
have to separate our ways i lose every
part of my business
i don't have a gig that i would lose so
i'm gonna put it out there
you would do it oh hundred percent for a
million
that's hard would you have sex with your
wife on there nah five mil
no no that not five mil but yeah
hear me out here that's a five mil hear
me out here once a month
that's hear me hear me out here one
that's 60 million a year
okay here hear me out 60 mil i would
have to ask her
obviously we're gonna we're gonna blur
out her face
but people are still gonna know it's her
because it's
gonna blur out her face but here's my
here's my thing like i don't know if 60
mil is worth
what follows that for her scrutiny
i don't mind whatever anybody says that
i don't none of it
what all right what about this none of
it what about what about
10 mil or 5 mil a month but
you have sex with somebody else would
your wife be like hey i'm going to make
60 mil but i have to [ __ ] somebody else
on i i'm
again because i i think that ends up
whether she thinks it'll be fine or not
that ends up ruining my marriage and
that's not worth it to me all right you
can wear a mask
but i she still knows i'm [ __ ]
somebody else right my wife does
yeah so that's going to ruin the
marriage so i think that's not but
i will say this i would
for sure uh then the other reason i
don't want to have sex
i don't want people critiquing the way i
[ __ ] you know are you going to read
the comments
i'd have to oh no i'd have to no
and then leave a comment what's worse
reading the comments from your comedy
special or from somebody watching you
[ __ ]
probably watching you [ __ ]
dude you gotta be cause you didn't leave
a comment for special anyway
to to pay like it's like a hater on your
patreon yeah but you know what it is i
can't imagine someone paying
and then leave a comment you're like but
dude you hate him you paid me
dollars yeah special kind of hater
here's the thing though like
this is gonna sound weird but my comedy
is almost more personal you know what i
mean like you're 100
if you but also there's not like you
know
like if i watch porn this guy's a
professional yeah i'm not like god how
do you do that
like there's sometimes peace out much
thicker teeth the dick bend like that
yeah but it's not it's not like you know
the only time i ever go what
is every now and then when you watch a
porn and like the dude has a serious
bend
like to the right or left and his dick
i'm like how's that gonna
fit like i was pretty good more i'm more
curious with the girl oh my god how can
she
take yeah like is that coming directly
out the side
of her body yeah somehow i'm like how
are we going to do that yeah like and
sometimes
obviously i'm trying to figure it out
this is the difference between me as a
young man
and an older person watching it
sometimes like the size of the dick i'm
doing math i'm like
well that that has to be up near her
sternum yeah some of it like that how is
that there's no way
where is that go are we gonna do this
where does that go and then sometimes it
takes so big
it's like it's you know it's kind of
it's like so big with a
there's just not enough blood to fill
that thing up yeah dude it's hard at the
base
but then at the front and so he has to
guide it in
i'm like ah it's like it's like a horse
dick
yeah because he's like i'm almost
light-headed he's like poor guy dude do
you know
how we gonna do this i did i interviewed
a guy
um so there's i forget how many in the
world but there are guys who have two
penises
i'm sure have you ever heard about the
guys it's called diapalactus or
something
two like straight-up dicks functional
they look normal it looks kind of like
there's one guy who has like a function
of two functional eight inchers or is it
like diapha
is that like red feet diphthalia yeah
diphallia let me see a picture chin
no they're really it's it's it's just
like two normal dicks
dude and so i asked him you know what
the guy who i interviewed
told me oh wow that's pretty normal he
told me
that one he goes yeah one's that's not
the guy i interviewed well that looks
this is crazy that one see that that
looks more like
so wow this really cool the guy told me
that one
of his penises was so he can urinate and
ejaculate
at the same time one can do either the
the wires are yeah one can do each and
he also the guy interviewed told me
that one the one was gay and one was
straight i'm like that's not how that
works dude
you're just gay homeboy yeah that's it
that's just you know you can tell
whoever you want that but the dick
doesn't decide
but also that that one is he got lucky
double lucky
i mean he's a good sized jerk that's but
if you can tie your dicks in a knot
boy that is insane isn't that bananas
i don't know that i would want that by
the way just for the record like
that so it seems like more of a cat is
that something like if a guy was like
hey i've got
two dicks that doesn't seem like a plus
does it it's just a lot it's it's
overwhelming it seems like a lot of
women i'm overwhelmed
that seems like a lot to worry about
right that's a lot to worry about but at
the same time i feel like i know a
couple girls who would love that
oh yeah really yeah more dicks the
better
for some of the girls
look at look at this patch i don't know
why why did he leave him
cut it that way you know yeah i mean
that's an interesting choice for how
you're going to do that
his head is disgusting the head of those
dates
oh i thought you were talking about his
face i'm like we have a picture of his
face what's up i didn't even know that
yeah those are just
two dicks yeah normal dick so it's just
so
so like never heard of it that's
fantastic yeah it seems like a
a something that i would not enjoy but
yeah he he
he to talk to him the guy that i talked
to
not that dude in particular but i did
talk to a guy who had to for an
i interviewed a guy and it was just like
i said
what's it like do you ever surprise he
goes no you have to i've
surprised one person the bad idea and he
said it's just a
it was it it scared her oh yeah
so you have to let them know ahead of
time i have to and i said how do you let
them know and he said i just say
hey just so you know if we go back to my
place
i'm not carrying two guns i've got two
dicks and she was like
you have like a dildo and he was like no
i have
two dicks
yeah yeah yeah i mean like you it's like
what yeah it's it's go
time it's a double shift yeah what
double header
yeah it's a double yeah what yeah but he
says he's going to
let them know some women
who don't some women are like cool
let's go back i can't say a hundred out
i can't say 100 i'm how would you
approach a woman i would say
i'd say hey you know when you get those
popsicles and they have like two steaks
in them do you enjoy them yeah
like i guess yeah you ever cut in two
and try
no would you like to i guess
yeah well that's what i'm dealing with
you know like yeah you gotta
you gotta give them a good visual yeah i
would definitely i was my analogy was
gonna be a twix bar you know the left
and the right are kind of the same
skinny though yeah well you know i'd say
do you like bananas she's like yeah like
you were trying
two at the same time she's like no like
have you ever thought about it
because bananas are thick yeah it
doesn't by the way again don't do this
on camera but it's a lot how many times
oh dude i don't get yeah
photoshop i mean you're gonna have 12
dicks
like have you ever been on a motorbike
like what
that's what it's like with me all the
time yeah i i yeah i don't know
a good way to i think the best of the
popsicle
the popsicle because you can squish it
obscure yeah you split them but you
gotta eat both the same time because
they melt
you know you save one we're not gonna
save anything no we're gonna go
but what happens if she only goes she's
like i'm down to do it but i'm just
gonna do the right side
i wonder if that causes issues on the
left side well i i
i i never asked him
if one can get pleasured but the other
one doesn't
like does one stay hard is he jacking
off this one while she's servicing that
one
but if you're masturbating by if you're
jerking yourself off
do you are you two-timing like are you
are you just doing one
and one later like i didn't ask you
just shooting like i know
that like milking a cow i don't know man
that is
again i was mind-blowing i wouldn't want
that kind of responsibility seven this
is
breaking news to me yeah straight up
i've never heard of this yeah i you know
the one thing i've never googled
is if there is which i'm gonna want to
leave here if there's porn with
guys if there's a double dick porn the
answer is yes
you think for sure there's double dick
porn saying this is breaking news to me
and i guarantee you there's porn on
everything there's
some dude in brazil named bazooka
[ __ ] benny silva yeah and it's just
double [ __ ] acai sick and it's just
fat dude what's the word you use
it american say though yeah you're
really pronouncing every letter but i
said akai when i went to brazil i was
like
is there any akai's around everyone's
like jesus christ dude
the kai's okay so now i correct everyone
well i don't i i think that's one set
that's breaking news to me dude
that's a sexual oddity i would not want
just like i wouldn't want i know there's
some people who have a penis and a
vagina no
i wouldn't want that what is it called
hermaphrodite hermaphrodites wasn't
jamie lee one of those there was rumors
about british
come on that might have been a rumor i
feel like there's always rumors about
like i heard that about megan fox
growing up heard that about lady gaga
no hermaphrodites yeah i always way too
fine kelly yeah
huge fan yeah i like that guy too did
you watch the mtv awards last night i
did watch some of them yeah i knew you
were yeah i did watch
them they were good yeah for what it is
how about lady gaga with a mask
i'm going to tell you right now i'm a
huge miley cyrus fan
and i'm a huge uh lady gaga fan you know
why i like lady gaga
she performs her own instruments she
writes her own [ __ ]
she's a performer man and i can feel how
much she
cares about yeah dude i didn't like that
miley cyrus was lip syncing
yeah i don't like lip syncing
in general i also don't like my big
honestly dude my big complaint with
modern music
pop music or whatever is that it's just
too produced
yeah like one of the things i used to
love about say when you still hear a foo
fighter's album
is you can hear growl leave his fingers
slide down the
neck of the guitar you hear him yeah you
can hear him breathe
when he's to to hit a big nose they take
a lot of sound like he sounds on the
radio like you can tell it's a live
like effort yeah yeah yeah and so i i
think taking the human part out of music
bums me out has taken me out a lot of it
i want to hear
you i want to hear some of these
performance they filmed
weeks ago really edited in which
well you could tell like obviously the
winners had to be told ahead of time
because i think if you're not a winner
they're like well i don't want to show
up a place if i'm not going to be
winning
but i thought they ran it well i thought
the woman who hosted it did a great job
is she a comic i think she's a singer
kiki
or a performer right yeah i thought
i think she makes some music but she's
predominantly an actress
she's so pretty and i thought she was
really good did she do
go to her wikipedia is she an actress i
thought she was a cop maybe she comic no
not a comic american actress
i think she's one of those people who
were like uh like youtube she does a
little bit of everything
she's cool yeah i thought she was really
good man i thought she was great i think
they should give her another run at it
too
yeah when uh it's live in front of a
crowd i agree with you
you know what last night though really
cemented for me is that especially
is that there's rock and roll is not
a viable like you know they said best
rock
was a by the way it was just like
earlier tonight we showed best rock and
i was like gone
yeah it's not it's there is no
representation of that
at all and i wonder dude because look
jacob listens to hip-hop because i
listen to rock so hip-hop was cooler
i wonder since this generation is going
to be like
you know what kevin at barstool yeah he
listens to hip-hop
his when he was young he did so i wonder
if his kids will rebel against that
and go back to rock do you know what i
mean like do you talk about old school
rock
you have to go to classics is what else
you gonna listen to i don't know maybe
the younger kids
that gen the next generation down
because you don't want to listen to what
your parents are listening to
so what's after hip hip-hop that's going
to be rebellious
do they go back to now i know latin
music is taking off a little bit huge
so maybe latin music gets its shot at
being more mainstream
but i'm wondering what it takes for rock
and roll to come back
and and i know kids that are playing
guitar growing up and all that [ __ ]
but you don't hear it on the radio
what's the last
big rock band do you consider fall out
boy rock
like they were up for rock my chemical
romance were they rock alternative frog
like who's a modern rock band
young oh uh what's that band that's kind
of they kind of sound like zeppelin
uh oh i can't believe i can't remember
the name
red hot chili pepper still doing the
thing but they don't have anything new
what this i can't believe i can't
remember the name of this band
greta van fleet greater man fleet have
you heard greta van fleet no they're
good
yo they they are they dudes
we actually talked about this a while
ago on a show what did we say
like it was awesome yeah they do have a
definite
zeppelin sound but and they're big
i mean i think i i don't know
i have no idea one of their videos what
kind of numbers they get they look cool
but they're definitely old they have an
old school feel
and i like that man old school vibe 70s
kind of updated clothes
that's how i want my rockstars to look
by the way yeah not like that but yeah
here's the best thing about rock stars
you can wear what the [ __ ] you want what
dude you ever go back and watch when the
like br like they
uh they had eyeliner on and [ __ ] come on
the 80s look at look what's he wearing
stick in your face
and by the way you shouldn't wear pants
that split your nuts jesus
you got to keep your nuts in one you
know what i mean your your
your nuts should never look like two
feet that's tough like sticking out the
side that is called the mousse
knuckle moose knuckle by the way i can't
tell you why because it's a
private shoot but and it's i signed a
non-disclosure so i won't tell you what
but i
hosted a show recently this week
past week where they brought me up on a
boom lift
probably 30 feet in the air and they put
a dart board
over the guy's face but his the rest of
his he was exposed
butt naked and i had to throw darts down
and try to hit the dartboard i missed a
bunch
dude there was some darts deeply lodged
in this
stomach christ dude it was a bananas i
can't wait when it comes out
i can't wait to tell you that was the
thames thing that happened
jesus christ oh but the new faces of
death i
love that [ __ ] dude faces of death
remember that
yes that [ __ ] vhs tape where you're
like i gotta show you something bro
that was the first original to me viral
video
dude it that that that and the um the
santa claus versus jesus that
that got passed around that was that was
basically how south park started did you
guys saw that
jesus santa claus were trey and matt's
first real oh really and they fought
it's i'm sure and it got passed around
in an old vhs tape
but same with with um yeah there it is
not news
same with um the faces of death face to
death was so dumb it was like an old v8
some people said somewhere it's fake i
guess you hear that i did
real to me it was it seemed so scary
the the part where they were eating that
monkey brain did not no
i did not really have those parents
that's dividing into alligators
yeah they seemed pretty real some of
them i could see how maybe you would
think it wasn't real to me yeah i would
look it if it keeps me up i agree that's
real we have some current events
yep let me pee before we do i get so bad
okay all right here we go
so the actor chadwick boseman actually
passed away a couple days ago to colon
cancer
bummer turns out he didn't tell anybody
he filmed all of those
movies had he got chemo chemo surgeries
knew how about he would post stuff
people would make fun of for losing for
losing weight
they go you look like [ __ ] dude little
annoying stage four [ __ ] colon cancer
you morons those people that left those
comments
you have no idea what somebody's going
through why would you leave a comment
like that
you know what was really heartbreaking
man is obviously
such a young dude and by all accounts
just a
good guy but
the idea of representation to see the
the
uh so so many pictures of young black
kids
just crushed putting up the black
panther dolls and
and seeing the white kids too my son has
a black black panther marvel dude
without a doubt but like to read some of
the captions of some of the parents
saying
how hard these kids were hit because it
was the one it was the one that they
related
yeah it was their first one was their
superman yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he was young
how many people that dude
and he played so many
it was interesting to tell i've been
going over interviews that he did
to hear him talk about how he approached
playing actual people do you see jackie
robinson he played a lot of actual
people
dude when he played uh the uh
god what um thurgood marshall right now
uh get on up when you play james brown
[ __ ]
he's so good in james brown uh thurgood
marshall is that the right word is that
the right name
yes okay um he was i didn't see the
james brown movie i saw a couple of
he's that's his best role he's so good
that's his best
oh it's his best he's so [ __ ] good at
that dude is he is it better than black
panther
yeah i'm not black panther fan what what
what now i don't think it was the best
marvel movie
but what was it you didn't like about it
i don't really [ __ ] with those movies
i don't like like i don't like avengers
i like captain america oh okay i like
wolverine
you don't like superhero movies i like
batman
you i like the more realistic like i
don't like like uh
fast and furious when they jump off
buildings like i don't like i don't like
that
okay let me ask you what's more
realistic what's more realistic
a superhero from outer space
like superman superman okay who
bullets don't affect yep or a
normal man who has somehow built talk
about bruce wayne
built a suit that is light enough
that he can do incredible stunts and he
can fight 50 000 people at once
but also bullets just bounce off of that
don't bother that's pretty realistic
but that's elon musk but that he can
this dude can beat the [ __ ]
he can just come down with a belt that's
pretty realistic like let's say
jon jones somehow won the lottery he
could be batman
i think there's more of a chance that
there's an alien than there could be a
bat then there could be a batman no way
if a rich dude learned how to fight and
like let's say elon musk had like legit
fighting skills yeah you'd be batman
you're just come on
technology over superman like lasers out
of your [ __ ] eyes dude
yeah yeah i mean listen once we're going
into atlanta unbelievable i'm in all of
it you know
i just i yeah i don't get that like i
only read nonfiction
i don't i don't [ __ ] with star wars star
trek no
no none of that even when you were a kid
never what about cartoons
uh i like rick and morty what so when
you like you
watch documentaries and reality shows
that's it in sports yep
because you like the human condition
yeah i like the real [ __ ]
i love it i love i live in conditions
yeah war books
dude nazi stuff by the way charles
manson i'm gonna get you this book
the wild that book that but oh yeah
it's about a lady doing it though it is
man but it's
i'm telling you dude what people go
through by themselves
i think it's called into the wild is
that right it's just wild i mean or the
do you ever read the or not read did you
ever watch the movie with
james franco i read the book and watched
it was it 247 hours some [ __ ] yeah um
you talking about uh nine hours or eight
hours no i got it whatever
eight hours homeboy what's it called
what was the movie called 127 hours yeah
and it was like a bunch of hours
yeah he like salts through his arm do
you i don't fantastic i don't think i
would have if
with that little butter knife he had to
get for death i
i like to think i could do it see my
kids again yeah when he hits that nerve
especially when you see the knife i'm
like okay if it was like this
sharp as [ __ ] i just i'm getting through
it but to really
have to dig in i like to think i can do
to see my kids again
it is so fascinating i heard the guy's a
raging [ __ ] by the way
you know what's funny though man you say
that you'd like to
people would like to believe they would
do the right thing
people would like to believe they would
do the heroic thing
but man i you just never [ __ ]
no you just never no you know what i
mean like
the only time i've ever been faced with
something like extreme like dazzling my
house got broken into
and i was going in i'm on the phone with
the cop and i know the guy's in my house
with my
son who at the time's like wait what
months you know i heard this story now
tell the full story on there but
so my i'm leaving to do a set at the
commie store my girl's like
uh i thought you left like i did she's
like telling me someone's trying to get
out of you no
no one's trying to get in i left like 10
minutes ago she goes tell me somebody's
[ __ ] with the back door i'm like no
crack we're here this one we live in the
palisades
kicks through the glass door and the
two men enter the house full get up
[ __ ] professionals you have cameras
we have cameras okay
i race back i'm on the phone with the
cops and they're like do not go in there
do not wait for the cops and like
there's somebody in my house
coming in with my wife and my kid i'm
[ __ ] going they go do not go and i go
not an option i'm going to all right
well leave us on speakerphone
and right when i pulled up i can see i
can see through that the doors kicked in
they're in there i can see
you know stuff going on they're in there
and in my mind i'm like
[ __ ] they have guns dude like that goes
for one second like dude yeah should you
wait and then
that just takes over like [ __ ] my kid
click yeah i've rushed in
and and it's a whole story where they
didn't want me to tell the story got it
yeah i'll tell you officially
off here yep i heard a story that ll
cool j can you look that up
no that's that's true you heard that we
had the same answer so he worked some
dude
over right yeah we had the same manager
at the time and that's the story he told
me i'm like alright well that does
nothing for me
so he so somebody broke into his house
and
he beat the [ __ ] out of the door he beat
the [ __ ] out because by the way that's
not a small guy
no and that's how i was before i was
never a gun guy not a big
like dog guy dude i mean i have three
ak-15s now
you know you got a [ __ ] security dog
yeah security at the gazoo
yeah yeah listen you know i'm not
because after that i'm like well we
don't have any guns or nothing so it's
like
if the if the burglar criminal comes in
with a gun you don't have one
it's a bad guy with a gun versus i can
fight
yeah but i don't have a gun so it
doesn't matter we got one
also but my wife not a big gun person
i i wouldn't consider myself to be a
huge gun person but
i always feel like let's just have a
couple of bad guys have them
the only way to beat a bad guy with a
gun is a good guy let's just let's just
have a couple but the truth is
no use in having a gun if you're not
going to go get trained with it oh for
sure there's just
no use in having a gun if you're not
going to go i got a tear in tactical
that's where i got my guns from yeah
they're literally three
ar-15s i mean they got the scope on how
many people
do you think are bringing in at once
don't know
don't know the world's crazy dude the
world's crazy
yeah three you have three one for me one
for my girl and one for one of the kids
you never know tiger four
those things are so easy you can
probably do it just make sure he's got
his ear things and you don't want him
yeah crazy what else you got uh check
this out
is it in taiwan is it got a kite
festival
and then i did you see this i saw this
this is
so insane yeah a little girl got caught
up no
yep what the end of the night
she's like says three years old let me
play the part where she gets caught up
keep watching this look at this
keep watching look how high this [ __ ]
gets
oh my god
and she's holding on she is i think
she's wrapped like it just caught her
is there someone staring the cat at this
point yeah someone has it on this side
pull down i mean because it's in the
tail of it they have the the front of it
oh my god and then finally boom they
caught her
holy [ __ ] did you see how high that
thing got yeah that'd be that is just
insane that is crazy
that is insane i can't
i don't know so as a parent how my
brain computes that if i was sitting
there watching that
there's no no no there's no there's no
way to even compute like
how where your mind goes on that i
i would have no idea i would have tried
to do the
follow it around and it is weird yeah
100 like yeah like
like catching up dude yeah exactly like
the highest pun of all time
yeah but uh it is like i was on a lake
balboa with my family my son wanted to
go on those swan boats yeah
and we go to the middle of the lake i'm
the only one peddling him that's a good
leg
[ __ ] i was bike riding earlier a day
and i'm like oh if we get stuck out or
something like that
and then my son's like flipping out but
then your mind starts thinking i'm like
worst case scenario if we got stuck this
we have left vests on so
it's very weird as a parent you go
through worst case
and like this is what i'll do here
that's what i'll do here even when i'm
in a movie theater
i sit by the exit i sit in the back by
the exit i watch everybody that comes in
see if they have anything
and then in my it's such a shame that
you bring things like this i'm like okay
if a shooter comes in we're gonna go out
this way
i tell my son hey shoot this what we're
gonna do it's like what the [ __ ] but
dude
we're at minions but yeah but i'm
talking about a master
but dude the thing is is that like it's
such a bummer
it is a bummer but it's interesting how
your brain
shifts to not always thinking about you
first after you have a kid but pre-kid
would you have thought i gotta sit in
the exit no way
it's be because you when you you're
always thinking
how do i keep that little person safe
well it's like i used to bring him
hiking with me all the time where i bike
ride all the
every week three four times a week we
would hike man hike
and people would go dude watch out
rattlesnake watch out rashling's like
there's no rattlesnakes
and then now i've been biking more and
seeing how there's so many
his athlete hiking there anymore do you
think do you think um
most parents are more cautious
or make their kids or try to make their
kids lead a more cautious life than they
did
do you know do you know what i'm asking
do you do i'm definitely more hey like
my dad
we are does your son do you try to make
your son lead a more cautious life than
say your dad made
100 like my my dad was more like yeah
you'll figure it out right get hurt
you'll learn not to do it like i'm like
no i don't want him to get hurt
like i'm honest but how like because i
know when your kid gets hurt it hurts
your heart oh my god but i truly believe
man that you have to fall to learn to
get up you have to fail
i agree i agree but it's a weird
counterintuitive to how you think
as a as a father because you're like
well if if this little person is crying
it hurts my heart so much it's like my
tiger he's four and boston's nine months
but boston is a big nine month old
and my girl she's like tiger's too rough
with him i'm like
but whenever he's getting rough you stop
it like he doesn't
to him it's loving like you gotta let
him let him if
boston christ will know not to be that
hard again so kind of just
back off a little bit so he realizes
like i can do this i can't do this
otherwise he just doesn't know it'll
like grab them and like
hug them and like you know boston's a
little uncomfortable he's not crying
you know so i'm like just let him kind
of figure out as long as he's not body
slamming but if they're just on the
ground rolling around like
they'll figure it out i think so and i
and i think it's also good for boston
i understand because you you there are
gonna be times in your life and nine
months is hard to learn the lesson
but there are times in your life where
that other person is bigger and faster
and stronger
and and you might be in a situation
where you gotta just figure out how i
don't like this how am i going to get
out dude today i've been off all day
because
uh i hate vaccinations for my own
personal reasons that how it affected my
son
it gave him seizures and that's how i
got started with cbd
so i'm i [ __ ] hate the men i i
believe in vaccinations i think they're
good
but um my family's in the one percent
who had a negative huge negative effect
yeah so i [ __ ] hate them
but just because it happened at tiger
doesn't mean it's gonna happen to
boston's so we have to get his shots
today do it's all i've been thinking
about
since 9 45 i've been looking up that's
why i keep checking my phone yeah
then finally my girl's like he did it
he's fine dean dean his fat ass
even though they're hilarious they they
give him
they give him a sucker that picture
he didn't even know she was like he
didn't even know he's fat ass even
yeah he's busy with the sucker i'm like
really like yeah
man let me tell you you feel like i said
in a picture i said hey boston says you
stole a snack yeah this
i was like that dude's got some cheerios
stuck somewhere
my i'm telling you man you feel your
kid's
pain when jacob was very young they had
to put him
you know if they're gonna x-ray ribs to
get a kid they have to almost put them
in not almost like they put them in
there
you strain them put them in a glass tube
and your arms are stuck like this
and they shut it well heartbreaking
tiger had to do it when they shut his
they pinched his skin and i could see it
and so
he was and i know this is a necessary
thing oh dude
but he's staring right out you almost
fight the doctor he's yes dude he's
staring at me
he's crying and he's saying come get me
this hurts come get me and i'm like
you know look i know i sound like a
[ __ ] and you know it's what your kid
needs to do
but every fiber of your body is like
[ __ ] this we'll
we'll live with whatever ailment you
have i can't i ca i can't be here
look at me like this and not it did not
say tiger got pneumonia when he was like
two so they put him in that [ __ ] tube
but they had to hold him down to x-ray
his uh
lungs dude and he's like fighting crying
and i had to leave the room yeah joanna
was like you gotta get out here
because i would get him i'd like he has
pneumonia all right give him what he
needs i'd [ __ ] drag him out
look at these [ __ ] look by the way
boston
does not have a small head oh he's huge
he's a big
dude oh well the the pediatrician today
was like oh he's
way bigger than tyler at nine months
he's gonna be huge
how much bigger is he he's 99 percent
out across the board like tiger was 90
percentile like height but not weight
but boston there's like yeah he's
probably gonna be a left tackle yeah
i mean i'm looking at that kid so big
what size is that batman onesie that i
think i could fit that's a 13 year old
you got that from the halloween store
it's
insane dude is he already physical like
can he oh yeah what's he do can he
walk and crawl and he can walk so he
walked before he crawled which is so
weird
yeah get on the the table and use it and
then walk around
and i'm like how the [ __ ] he walking
without crawling and dude and how's his
like
uh how is his hand on his motorcycle
kids yeah good
it's so crazy to see you know but you
know early on
by 8 10 12
you can tell people who are special and
kids who are just going to be
even before then yeah yeah like tiger at
four when like when they play soccer
you're just like oh okay
like yeah he's gonna be good he's the
athletic kid yeah as you can go the nfl
or i don't know but i know you can tell
for sure what were you saying
i mean like special but you can tell
special kids
a little bit older there's like a
separation period between 10 through 12.
dude i took tiger again to that uh
tempest gym and
when the instructor's kids were there
it's this little girl who's five
she was cute as [ __ ] her mom was after
100 afghani
and he's like mexican and they had this
baby and yeah the baby she had dark skin
but her eyes were piercing blue
she had this little ponytail in and her
dad's extreme sport like
he does he's a freestyle parkour guy
like one of the best in the world
he's one of the owners of tempest and
this little girl at
five dude i was like what the [ __ ] doing
like handstands
crazy jumping over this huge stuff and
with me i want to grab her like
let her do her thing man she's swinging
on the monkey bars her little ponytails
flapping i'm like what a badass yeah man
and like dude she was skateboarding at
two
like what like she was going down
mountain like
mountain like park city mountain bikes
at four i'm like
what the do you know what my kid was
doing it too he found his [ __ ] it's
not
yeah most kids he was like oh look at
that there's another hole down there
you know the dad was he he does extreme
sports so he's like
he's advanced with like that stuff so
he's like oh dude
learn a bike i just put on a bike i'm
like with training wizard no
you know what i just put her on a bike
and like she figured i just figured out
in a day i'm like
what but by what like probably so much
by watching
that's why i'm scared with my kids like
my kids will have watched me do some
weird [ __ ] i ate a live cockroach on tv
like okay yeah yeah yeah like they've
seen me do some weird
shits i'm wondering like i hope jacob
doesn't get that tiger's work he has
this weird
false sense of uh belief in himself
where he thinks he's faster than
everything
because i was telling you you're the
fast boy in the world and he's the
fastest [ __ ] kid on the field
but he thinks he's fast in every aspect
so he's like papa if we see a
rattlesnake i'm just i'm gonna grab him
i'm fast on me but you're not though
it's a rattlesnake
and then the other day we're at the
basketball court and there's all these
cobwebs i'm like why you gotta get these
cobwebs out so i'm spraying them
and a fat [ __ ] black widow falls to
the ground and he has a book of a black
widow that i read to him at night
it was papa black widow and he goes to
[ __ ] i'm like what are you doing dude
he's like i'm fascinated thing i'm like
no
you probably you probably are faster
than that black widow yeah but i
wouldn't touch him now
but he just like you know by the way it
doesn't matter if you're fast he's like
this
yeah i'm like what are you doing but he
probably feel
at four you're like i can [ __ ] with i'm
inventing it crazy yeah i can [ __ ] with
whatever
now you gotta pray to god he doesn't
stumble upon a rattlesnake because he
thinks he's faster than the rattlesnake
man but i'm like this is gonna pay off
down the road buddy
like in sports that kind of crazy
confidence dude this is nuts
i never had that kind of crazy
confidence that i mean that is a great
but i mean i i was very realistic about
how
fast i wasn't really i'm um
i had three older brothers that reminded
me yeah they were like i was like
i don't know where he gets that though
cuz i'm not like oh you're faster than
rattlesnake or you're this or
that you make him feel good about
himself dude but he really is the
fastest kid on the field so i'm like
you're the fast four-year-old when you
put new shoes on when you were four
didn't that make you seem faster
well you're like i'm gonna put my new
zips on and i can do it but he's
barefoot all the time so he's like
tarzan
so isn't it weird that is amazing i'm
like what the [ __ ] dude
hey i gotta oh [ __ ] it's 3 30. yeah i
got a jet oh sorry
dude i got a jet i gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta get you in trouble uh maybe
you know your chatty cats i don't really
chat again i love it man
um love you man love you dude
hey everybody comedian joshua.com for
tour dates
uh did you have something lined up
october yeah you know today's the first
day
uh this week is the first week that
austin's opening up at cap cities i'm
there at the end of this month
so they're like well we think it's still
on yeah so hopefully everything goes
well there i think
man i think people will start to figure
it out yeah i do i think
i think people start to figure it out is
if we can just stop
square math if we can stop yelling at
each other and just
figure figure out everybody wants to get
back to normal
every there's some doomsday [ __ ] out
there i agree the corona bros like
no never you know what i'm gonna stay in
our basement get on employment but most
people want to get
i agree okay and so let's all just
figure out the smartest way
just be cool yeah to do that be cool
with each other man
you sound like me dude just be cool just
be cool man that's where i got it dude
yeah
yeah yeah the comedian joshua.com and
all my other [ __ ] appreciate you brother
thank you the best
appreciate it